There's no tea in this kind of place.
Watch TV. It's
near here. Why is this a secret? We're
running away too.
Why did you guys plan the attack? That
's a good question.
Good luck!
From the Armed Detective Agency.  Folks,
this was a
message that arrived at the detective agency six days ago in the afternoon. Now,
of course you know what happened after this.
[Music]
And the detective agency that went to the rescue
was framed as the perpetrator of a terrorist attack.  If
there's any evidence, it's this.The
same thing was sent to all police-related facilities this morning.Fingerprints from the crime scene.Changes in the
plans for the hair hostage.His
purchase history for a chainsaw.Assuming that the
detective agency prepared a terrorist attack, this is
impossible evidence or the absence of evidence.  I
compiled it into a document.
You are there too.
Where is that envelope? Why are you
throwing it away unopened?
Because of the power of politics, no one believes in the innocence of the detective agency anymore. The
page is a special psalm with the ability to alter reality.
Everything written in the book is true.The true
culprit wrote there that the
Armed Detective Agency was the mastermind behind Tenjin's recent incident,
and
police officials
believed that the Armed Detective Agency was the culprit and had no doubts about it.The
documents are now available.  He must have been abandoned. Well, I guess it's
about time. I'm
leaving now, but I
want to say to the police officers who are watching this: Don't think based
on your position or occupation.
Think based on your own soul.